اكدت السفاره الروسيه لدى واشنطن ان
التدابير الامريكيه المضاده في سياق
معاهده تخفيض الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
والهجوميه ستارت لن تؤثر على موقف روسيا
واشارت لان الاتهامات الموجهه لها من قبل
الخارجيه الامريكيه بانتهاك المعاهده لا
علاقه لها بالاسباب الحقيقيه للازمه وكانت
الخارجيه الامريكيه قد قالت ان واشنطن
باشرت امس الخميس حجم اشعارات معاهده
الجديده عن روسيا بما في ذلك مواقع
الصواريخ والقاذفات واضافت الخارجيه في
بيان ان الولايات المتحده اوقفت مشاركه
بيانات القياس عن بعد مع روسيا بشان
عمليات اطلاق الصواريخ الباليستيه من
الغواصات واكدت الخارجيه ان واشنطن اتخذت
تلك الخطوات ردا على انتهاكات موسكو
المستمره لمعاهده ستارت الجديده مشيره في
الوقت ذاته الى ان واشنطن ملتزمه
بالتنفيذ الكامل والمتبادل للمعاهده